et dans le reste de l'actualité les
sirènes ont encore retentissent matin
dans le ciel ukrainien nouvelle menace
de bombardement sur les villes de qui
avait Mikola if notamment à l'heure où
les regards sont braqués vers le front
sud Carson ou inoffensive de l'armée
ukrainienne apparaît imminente on en
parle avec vous-même charrier bonjour
Armelle les autorités prorus sont ont
commencé effectivement hier ou en tout
cas non c'est transférer une partie de
la population ce qui présage a priori
d'une offensive assez imminente oui
parce que du côté des Russes on parle de
50 à 60 000 personnes qui vont passer de
l'autre côté de la rive du Nieppe
puisque du coup elles seront hébergées
soit en Russie soit en Crimée et donc ce
qui est frappant c'est que on voit
clairement que il y a une stratégie
militaire derrière tout ça pour les
Russes à partir du moment donné où vous
repliez et que vous choisissez l'une des
rives du Nieppe la rive droite en fait
du coup vous êtes protégé par le fleuve
et on voit clairement que du coup c'est
se préparer à un assaut se préparer à
une bataille qui va dans logique de ce
qu'on avait vu lorsque l'on les avait vu
tracer des une sorte de frontière un peu
comme la ligne Maginot pour empêcher que
les chars ne s'en aille et là cette
fois-ci c'est aussi les hommes et les
femmes qui sont tenus en quelque sorte
parce que à partir du moment donné où
vous enlevez des civils vous amenez une
confrontation militaire qui dans ces
clubs vont être d'autant plus violentes
que si les ukrainiens et les Russes sont
entre militaires et n'ont plus rien à
perdre donc on voit effectivement cette
notion-là quant à la population elle se
retrouve en fait entre deux choses
c'est-à-dire que vous avez certainement
une partie de la population qui doit
être prorus et qui donc dans ces cas-là
peut-être soulagée de partir elle ne
choisit pas sa destination mais ça peut
être le cas et puis vous avez aussi une
partie qui doit subir ce qui est en
train de se passer et qui peut
effectivement se retrouver à aller en
Russie alors qu'elle n'ait eu le désire
pas et que ça sera plus compliqué par la
suite la loi martial a été décrétée hier
par Vladimir Poutine concrètement
qu'est-ce que ça ça signifie pour ce
conflit et pour les les hommes et les
femmes qui vivent dans ces régions alors
pour l'instant ça signifie par grand
changement mais ça donne un cadre
militaire à partir du moment donné où
vous avez une remerciale qui est mise en
place il y a toute une série d'actes que
vous pouvez faire effectivement parce
que si vous devez faire un appel
justement à des soldats si vous devez
aller enquêter dans des maisons si vous
devez ouvrir des endroits pour voir s'il
y a des caches d'armes ou si vous devez
effectivement amener les gens à
combattre vous êtes effectivement dans
ce cadre là vous pouvez aussi avoir un
couvre-feu quand vous avez une noix
martial par exemple c'est surtout aussi
un geste quelque part politique et ça va
dans le sens de cette offensive
c'est-à-dire que pour les Ukrainiens la
journée d'hier ça a été forcément
compliqué vous aviez ce qui était
annoncé sur Carson vous avez cette loi
martiale vous avez ces drones qui
viennent frapper le drone kamikaze qui
fait vienne frapper les villes donc ça
fait beaucoup beaucoup d'éléments plus
le fait que certains se retrouvent
maintenant sans électricité se retrouve
sans sans eau et du coup comme ça rend
les choses compliquées et puis la loi
martiale c'est aussi un message
politique pour les Russes à l'intérieur
du pays c'est à dire de la part de
Vladimir Poutine la capacité à dire
voilà ce que nous mettons en place en
Ukraine doucement on est en train de
passer à autre chose qu'à l'opération
spéciale et aller effectivement ça ça
notion de guerre à cela se rajoute en
dernier mot le fait que le général russe
qui maintenant est en charge des
opérations a dit que c'était un contexte
particulièrement tendu et de l'opinion
russe a été plutôt favorable à cette
terminologie en disant voilà quelqu'un
qui nous parle vrai ça s'inscrit voyez
dans le fait d'avoir la loi martiale et
dans le fait d'avoir des évacuations de
civile merci beaucoup Armelle pour le
décryptage